MAHESH NARAYANAN: Like
many developers interested
in microservices, you start off
dabbling with Google Kubernetes
engine or a powerful cluster
manager and orchestration
system for running
your Docker containers.
First, you accept
all the defaults
and then slowly start
modifying a few parameters
to support your application.
BOWEI DU: As you
spend more time,
your confidence increases.
More traffic and
mission-critical applications
move to GKE, which is great.
You will be able to benefit
from GKE's advanced cluster
management features.
MAHESH NARAYANAN: Soon enough,
your cluster size gradually
starts increasing.
Things seem to be going
fine until one day,
when you start hitting
scalability and manageability
issues that can often be
avoided by implementing
some key best practices
during cluster creation.
Over the next few
sections, we'll
be covering some of
the best practices
features and designs
in GKE networking that
can help you scale and
manage your GKE footprint
as your business grows.
BOWEI DU: First, let's talk
about VPC-native clusters.
As you know, Kubernetes mandates
direct pod-to-pod connectivity.
But there is more than
one way to achieve this.
By default, Kubernetes
uses static routes
for pod networking,
which requires
Kubernetes nodes control
plane to maintain
these routes to each node.
This comes at a scaling cost.
In GKE, we give you the
option to create clusters
in VPC native mode,
which provides
container-native networking.
VPC native mode is enabled
with a single click,
and it enables connectivity
between all the pods
in your VPC without the
overhead of route scaling.
The VPC control
panel automatically
manages routing setup for pods.
And the native integration of
container networking in the VPC
Fabric improves scalability and
integration between Kubernetes
and other VPC features.
MAHESH NARAYANAN:
Kubernetes also
makes very liberal
use of IP addresses,
which simplifies the system
and makes it easier to use
and comprehend.
But, on the flip side, this
makes IP management a challenge
for Kubernetes deployment.
This is exacerbated
in a hybrid deployment
or where IPs are fragmented,
making IPs a scarce resource.
VPC-native sources
better providing
flexibility in defining your
cluster scale requirements
upfront or resources like
pods, nodes, and services.
So instead of having 100
resources and thousands of IPs,
you can not have 100
resources and 128 IPs.
This allows for Kubernetes
to reduce its IP footprint,
thereby improving the
overall IP utilization.
BOWEI DU: VPC-- native clusters
also enable other enterprise
grade features, for example,
sharing VPCs between projects,
IM and role
separation, providing
anti-spoofing security in our
SDN stack, and also private
clusters for cluster isolation.
MAHESH NARAYANAN: Apart
from scaling, security's
another criteria that needs to
be considered in best practice.
Enterprise users
require a deployment
in which your
services and networks
are isolated and accessible
only within trusted boundaries.
GKE provides this
through private clusters.
Private clusters makes the local
node and the cluster master
accessible only within
the trusted boundaries.
Any unauthorized access your
control plane is set to default
deny.
For the road warrior
use case in enterprise,
private cluster also provides
a walled-garden access
to control plane through
private data points, which
is provisioned by the customer.
BOWEI DU: Another
best practice to be
aware of for
applications at scale
is how you expose your
services to the internet.
When you need to deploy
your applications,
you may start off using
a cluster-based ingress
controller, such as
Nginx or HAProxy.
This is really familiar
for a lot of us.
It's just a standard proxy that
you would run on your laptop.
You would then expose
your application
to the internet using a
layer-4 Kubernetes service load
balancer.
However, when your
application scales up,
you will want to use the Google
ingress implementation in GKE.
The GKE container-native
ingress is a globally scalable,
low-latency,
distributed proxy layer
that supports many of
the built-in features,
such as caching, authentication,
and DDoS protection.
You won't want to
fiddle with how many
instances of your proxies
to scale up to or worry
about how to absorb an attack.
MAHESH NARAYANAN: In
addition, the Google ingress
has built-in support for
container-native load balancing
using network endpoint groups.
This means that
the network traffic
will be balanced directly to
the container in your VPC,
skipping the order of bouncing
through the Kubernetes
kube-proxy layer.
You'll also be able to
easily debug your traffic,
as your connections no longer
need address translation
to get to their destination.
There are also other
certain advantages
of using Google ingress instead
of cluster-based controllers,
such as connection imbalance,
an accurate end-to-end health
checks for your back ends.
BOWEI DU: GKE makes the job of
deploying a scalable Kubernetes
much less daunting and
offers many features
that allow you to future
proof your deployment.
MAHESH NARAYANAN: We have only
scratched the surface here.
And there are many
other techniques
that helps in scalability and
manageability of your cluster.
Please attend the HYB 314
session at Next 2019 SF
to learn more about
these tools and tips.
[MUSIC PLAYING]